you're watching swipe coming up it's
lunch din but not as we know it we look
at the future of kitchen tech stolen
celebrity photos how the Jennifer
Lawrence hackers have made us all think
about privacy stand up be counted the
new website for 16 to 25 year olds and
there's murder and a dance floor in our
games review hello and welcome to slide
now if you're wondering why I'm
currently surrounded by chefs it's all
about to become clear because this week
we decided to take a look at kitchen
tech so many manufacturers and designers
competing to be the most innovative it
got us wondering what kinds of things
will we find in kitchens of the future
Duncan's kitchen is a haven for gadget
lovers whether you want to froth brew
juice or pulverize he's got it all this
bad boy is a vacuum packer and he's not
alone in his passion for culinary tech
apparently UK kitchens have an average
of seven gadgets which do you use this
with your sandwiches for work I use this
all the time Oh what was that
technology may not always make life
easier but that doesn't bother Duncan
that's part of the whole like again kind
of machismo in the kitchen sort of Iron
Chef kind of thing you know
no need topping things up with like big
sharp knives but you get to handle big
you know pieces of equipment he's got a
lot to look forward to manufacturers are
eagerly competing to come up with ways
of transforming our kitchens and years
to come we could be using interactive
cook tops like this one you can prepare
meals and surf the web at the same time
and we won't just be using our
appliances in the future we'll be
exchanging messages with them to
services like LG's home chats mean your
fridge for example can tell you how many
bottles of beer are left inside
and with hologram technology you could
cook and eat with family members while
they are on the other side of the world
we'll take a lesson from a holographic
chef there really just needs to be the
consumer demand for it so in the future
I expect there'll be a lot of settings
where we'll see the dining table look
very different to how it looks now you
might be able to beam grandma in from
somewhere very far away and she can be a
real part of your eating experience but
with designers so keen to be innovative
could we ironically end up taking a step
backwards but what really disturbs me
about technology and food now is people
have become so far removed from actually
just cooking their dinner
everyone thinks now that it's super
complicated to cook at home when actual
fact all any cook needs is a really good
knife a chopping board and a saucepan
that's all any cook needs holographic
chefs I think is a nightmare for Duncan
though futuristic developments in the
kitchen can't come quickly enough and I
think I guess if you're really into
technology and you really into
time-saving it's almost like you're not
gonna be quite satisfied until you've
got the point where the food is being
like in Star Trek kind of beamed into
your fridge and then a robot prepares it
serves it to you whilst you sit on your
sofa all day it's going to make watching
Sky News your vacuum packing and onion
lock obsolete you connect well I know
hard to believe for Monday people will
laugh at the idea of vacuum packing an
onion no surely not Duncan well the
kitchen I'm standing in right now is no
ordinary kitchen we're at Farah at
Claridge's in London where they use some
of the most state-of-the-art kitchen
appliances in the country and I'm joined
now by Chef Patrick Simon Rogan's and
executive chef Dan Cox thanks for
joining me guys with such advanced
technology does anything make your lives
easier or does it actually complicate
things from time to time
obviously you know for any any chef
worth his salt to create all the latest
creations need some top top class
equipments on the latest equipment a
couple with this we've got a very
advanced kitchen very advanced
extraction system and the latest tip
induction technology which is a very
cool and very nice kitchen to work in so
yeah it's got to be everything got to be
a good thing I can see it's a great
environment great environment but I'm
really distracted by what Dan is using
over here what is that and it's a rotary
evaporator we we today be using it so it
is still our P one with a base for our
p1 which they can Vestal vodka and then
infuse it with pea shoots for 24 hours
then we put it on to the rotary
evaporator and you've got dark green
liquid here and then we distill it under
pressure and a very low temperature and
we bring the over so it boils up into
this condensing class but there's
evaporation glass there's a clear spirit
which gives us a pea flavor popped up
essentially and we then use that to make
our pea wine cocktail
fantastic can I try it
I should really check it out in life
please don't such low temperatures you
know boils at 50 degrees so there's no
lot of nutrients or flavor so everything
is locked in there it's really really
nice but I can imagine though you have
to train all your staff to use this I
mean does that take a lot of time does
that complicate things it's easier to
need to use than you think
once we go through the other class
because they're very very delicate so
you can't be too heavy with it
they pricey to replace it's a lot of you
right yeah yeah they're expensive so
that's the downside of technology it's
always expensive to replace if it goes
wrong but we couldn't do about it you
know it's it's an essential tool for our
job but are there some dishes that you
much prefer to cook in the traditional
way to stick with an old-fashioned
process yeah we meat and fish we tend
not to use water bar so much anymore
then stick to official methods of of
hand roasting or you know using an oven
do you see that ever changing though
could you be tempted by gadget I've been
and roast perfectly I think there was a
water bath craze and Everett food became
much of the sameness but I think it's
coming back to full circle gain I think
the Jewish traditional methods are
coming to the form and we've got
barbecues here there's nothing better
than cooking over foil it's a it was an
instinct that we've had since the dawn
of time so you know sometimes the oldest
technique to lose the best I think it's
been really a testing tool with you both
thanks for having us and I'm going to
use this week Jennifer Lawrence hit the
headlines after some naked photos of her
stolen and circulated online and what
does that mean for our own online
privacy Stewart Duggan's been finding
out you can't have missed the story of
Jennifer Lawrence's leaked naked photos
over the last few days unless you've
been somewhere without access to the
Internet and speaking of connectivity
that is exactly what has caused this
problem for one of Hollywood's top stars
and more than 100 other celebrity
targets the FBI is investigating the
leak with the photos reportedly stolen
from Apple's iCloud service some of the
celebrity targets say the photos are
fakes actress Mary Winstead says the
pictures of her are real but that she
deleted them long ago
of course there's no doubt that the
celebrities who were targeted in this
hack have been wronged and their privacy
has been invaded but there is a certain
naivety most of us have when it comes to
these devices they're our phones our
tablets our computers but we forget that
they're also our gateway to the digital
world and with that comes the good and
the bad should we still be using the
cloud to store our material though and
how can we keep our data safe here are
some top tips and insights from cloud
technology specialist James Sinclair
having a replication of your data is
more valuable than not and so the
concept of going back to the stone Age's
and not saving anything online actually
doesn't serve your purpose in terms of
efficiency steps just have to be taken
change your password from Jim r11 that's
probably the biggest thing what do we do
today right now to protect us up number
one is we recognize that everything
digital goes somewhere and that's just
the end of the conversation so knowing
that you have to take good steps which
is don't use the same username and
passwords on every website again keep
them cryptic use two-factor
authentication if you can you know it's
very difficult to work out where your
data is and where your files are and
what you're doing with it and so Andy
don't really get this audit trail of
where your photo is going through
through the cloud or through the web or
through the interwebs once it's out
there in the ether just is you're
waiting swipe coming up is it a phone is
it a wallet could be both the latest
iPhone 6 rumors but first Sky News has
launched a new digital project aimed at
giving a voice to 16 to 25 year olds
it's called stand up be counted Tom
Platt has more a lot of 18 to 24-year
olds just on voting at the last election
only 44% of our age group did that means
more than half of us aren't influencing
who gets into power so we've launched
stand up be counted a new site for young
people to engage with current affairs
powered by Sky News it's easy to use you
register via the upload button at the
top of your screen all you'll need is a
profile picture and a few lines about
yourself after that you can upload a
short clip of you talking on camera
about something you're passionate about
the economy education whatever it is or
you can upload a picture or a blog post
you feel tells your story you can talk
about one of our hot topics of the week
and engage in debates on things like
youth unemployment or education or you
can use our open mic page to let rip
about something else that matters to you
whether it's bus passes or nuclear
energy one click on the site takes you
straight to the page where you can
register to vote something that if all
of us decided to register could really
transform the political landscape in the
country and the platform is available on
your mobile making it that bit easier to
get your voice heard plus you can share
the content you've made from the site on
loads of different platforms meaning you
can share your message with your friends
you're watching swype coming up if you
spot a vulnerability in Twitter's
security systems the social network will
now pay you a bug bounty Twitter says
it'll hand out at least 85 pounds for
every new bug reported and it hasn't set
a maximum on how much it'll pay but
you've got to be the first person to
report the vulnerability to be eligible
for the money you might want to be
careful how much time you spend on
social media though after researchers in
Rome found it may be making us miserable
they say networks like Facebook
increased the risk of being exposed to
offensive behaviors and hate speech it's
that kind of content that can apparently
reduce our trust in others leading to a
detrimental effect on well-being if
Apple has its way your phone could soon
become your wallet to the latest iPhone
6 rumors claim Apple has struck a deal
with Visa MasterCard and American
Express apparently a special chip will
allow owners to use their phones in a
similar way to a contactless payment
card the new handset is expected to be
revealed on September the 9th Samsung
launched two smart phones a SmartWatch
and a virtual reality headset at the
ephah consumer electronics fair in
Berlin this week the note for the Note
edge the gear s and the gear VR the
headset was developed with oculus VR the
virtual reality firm now owned
by Facebook and the Note edge comes with
a screen that wraps around the handset
also a Tifa motor roller announced its
first SmartWatch the Moto 360 will go on
sale in the UK in October competing with
rival models from LG and Samsung with so
much going on and Aoife we are Stan
grabbin to give us a breakdown of the
best bits according to him so here's my
top five things from Italy for 2014 at
number five the Samsung gear VR headset
it's a very cool - the virtual reality
headset that you put the note for
smartphone into the front of and it
projects the image onto your onto your
field of vision a number for the assumed
watch it's pretty cool it's a SmartWatch
powered by Android gear SmartWatch is
all the craze and hopefully we'll see an
Apple Smart Watch next week
and number three I'll go for the Sony
Xperia z3 smartphone very cool
smartphone it is dust and water
resistant and has 20 megapixel camera so
very impressive at number two are gopher
LG's 4k OLED TVs brilliant colors and
excellent brightness and they just look
terrific and in number one I'll go for
Samsung's Galaxy edge it's a smartphone
with a curved edge to the screen that
you actually can control different
functions on and you can have rolling
ticker updates a tweets or stock updates
now we like to think smart has something
for everyone
especially in our games review this week
we've got Sims we've got bizarre
morality tales we've got dancing and
we've got wars in space here's Lucy
James from GameSpot
dansant has been going for a while now
it is a rhythm exercise game where you
use the the xbox 360's camera which is
called the Kinect and you follow
on-screen prompts and you dance along
basically Dance Central spotlight is an
exclusive to Xbox one so it's using
Microsoft's new Kinect 2.0 so it's going
to have better motion tracking than
before because I know I've played done
Central and I've I've called out the
Kinect for not you know mapping my body
correctly Kinect 2.0 is a lot better at
that dance essentials great I mean to
get out of parties and just sort of
flail around with your friends and stuff
and that's yeah that's really what done
central spotlight is danganronpa
is a is a Japanese franchise to tell by
the name so this is a sequel to a game
that came out in the PSP so this game
actually itself came out on the PSP a
few years ago now and now here in the
West we're getting it on the PlayStation
Vita so it's quite an interesting very
quick bizarre japanese-style story so
you play as an amnesiac students you're
very you're you know top of your class
so you and these other skilled students
go to this you know tropical island
called Jabberwock and you're there with
your principal and then he says well
you're all stuck here forever unless you
can kill one of your classmates and get
away with it so that's kind of the basic
premise and I'm not going to go too far
because it gets even wackier there's
other stuff going on it's bizarrely
intriguing and really quite fun thanks
you get exciting so the sims 4 is the
latest game in the series um the big
changes they made it's the kind of
making the sims giving them putting more
into their personalities making each sim
more unique so you can affect the way
they walk now create a sim you know
there'd be a bunch of presets but now as
you kind of click on their face and drag
and you can make them sort of even more
unique and give them all these
personality traits so it's kind of fun
but the thing is that with the sims is
the first one there's always expansion
packs to add more items and stuff so
this is the base game and it means it's
not got a lot in what it does have is
this big online community that EA are
really pushing which publisher which
means so you can build you can create a
celebrity in create a sim you can make
like Beyonce or someone and upload it
and then someone can immediately
download that and put that into their
game so they're kind of building on that
community aspect so people can make
their own stuff and share it online very
easily there's no kind of big wacky
adventures that your sims can go on just
yet but the games coming out and they're
promising there's going to be a ton of
content coming but you just have to kind
of wait for it first
warframe is the first free-to-play game
to come through Microsoft ID'd Xbox
program which means they're kind of
giving help to smaller developers and so
the game is completely free to play but
inside the game and this is how the
developers make money is their store so
you can buy new you know weapons and
abilities things like that and you can
pay for that using either money you've
earned by completing missions and things
or you can spend real-world money and
get more expensive items without having
to play the game for hours and hours and
hours just to earn the money it's a free
game so you haven't really got much to
lose and if you like online playing and
it's third-person to smart it's you know
it's kind of different because normally
you'd get like a first-person game and
it's all you know question Eric and
stuff but this is third person and you
know there's a bit of parkour elements
in it's quite cool and a set in space so
you know everyone loves a good
thanks Lucy well that's it for this week
don't forget you can stay up to date
with all the latest breaking tech
stories on your iPad smartphone up as
Carney's calm I'll see you again next
time bye bye and Cheers